foreign
[Applause]
welcome to Hunt Valley Maryland and the
headquarters of zenimax online Studios
you just saw a cinematic teaser for The
Elder Scrolls online's next chapter
I'm pleased to reveal ESO necron which
will launch in June and is shaping up to
be one of the best updates to the game
ever
if you watch the teaser closely you saw
that necron will include one of the most
requested features in ESO a new playable
class called The Arcanist
it's only our third new class since
launch and we know you're gonna love it
the arcanus wields magic influenced by
Forbidden Knowledge and has unique
abilities never before seen in this
world
of course the experience of exploring a
new area of Tamriel was the heart of
every ESO chapter necron will unfold an
Eastern Morrowind not seen in an Elder
Scrolls game since 1994 where you will
meet new characters and enemies reunite
with some old friends and explore a
story based around the return of a
well-known Daedric prince you just might
remember from the Dragonborn Skyrim DLC
for those of you new to ESO we release a
new expansion called a chapter every
year chapters are essentially Standalone
games in ESO that let you Adventure in a
new region of Tamriel but you don't have
to wait for the necron chapter to jump
in we've got so many amazing experiences
you can enjoy right now if you love
games like Skyrim and Oblivion you'll
feel right at home amongst the thousands
of stories unfolding across every region
in ESO
and as anyone who's played a classic
Elder Scrolls game knows all about those
feelings when you're fully immersed in
the world
remember that feeling when you first
encountered a dragon
Province it's
inside Dragons
or questioned if you were capable of
taking down a frost troll in Skyrim try
it for yourself and ESO
what about the moment you visited a city
in Morrowind that was built inside the
shell of a giant crab
for the Oblivion fans out there how
about another chance at taking on the
Colossal Daedric prince merun's Dagon
just like any single player Elder
Scrolls game you can have a blast simply
by following the main quest line
or seek out lore and learn more about
the world
become a Craftsman
go fishing
decorate and furnish your home
[Music]
customize your character
play it like an action RPG and when
you're ready you can easily engage in
one of the best open world PVP systems
run dungeons co-op with your friends for
great loot or just join a guild to chat
with others
possibilities in this virtual world are
endless
players will immediately feel right at
home because our community is one of the
most if not the most welcoming on the
planet
we invite everyone who has not yet
experienced ESO to give it a try and
create your own stories in our shared
world there's no required subscription
and thousands of hours of content to dig
into Solo
or with friends
explore nearly every corner of tamrio
with no level restrictions it's magical
being able to travel almost anywhere you
please from the moment you enter the
world
ESO is available on PC and Mac in
addition to previous and current gen
consoles including a purpose-built
next-gen version for the Xbox series xns
with High Fidelity graphics and enhanced
performance modes an added bonus for
Xbox players it's on Game Pass
starting today for a limited time we're
making all past chapters available to
explore for any player so everyone can
test drive all of our adventures
including our take on Skyrim Morrowind
Oblivion and much much more
at zoss we have so many passionate and
talented developers who continue to add
to Elder Scrolls lore by producing
handcrafted Epic Adventures and I'm
immensely proud to be a part of it
believe me we have tons more to share
and I can't wait for the team to show it
all to you
join us after this show for the 2023 ESO
Global reveal where we'll go deep into
all things necron
thanks see you in Tamriel